jetzt gehen wir live rein und sprechen
über diese frage gleich angela merkel
die bundeskanzlerin am tag ausführlich
mit den regierungschefs und chefinnen
der bundesländer beraten telefonisch wir
alle sind uns des ernstes der situation
bewusst dass kronawitter es breitet sich
weiter mit besorgniserregender
geschwindigkeit in unserem land aus wir
haben heute darüber gesprochen wie
unsere gegenmittel greifen und an
gegenmitteln haben wir eben noch keinen
impfstoff und keine medikamente sondern
nur erstens die anstrengungen die wir
unternehmen um unser gesundheitssystem
vor allem die krankenhäuser auf den zu
erwartenden weiteren hohen anstieg der
fallzahlen vorzubereiten
und zweitens unser eigenes verhalten
das ist das derzeit wirksamste mittel
das wir haben
das bedeutet das öffentliche leben so
weit herunter zu fahren die es
vertretbar ist die begegnung der
menschen bei denen das virus weiter
gegeben werden könnte soweit zu
reduzieren wie möglich sie wissen dass
sich bund und länder zu diesem zweck am
montag bereits auf einschneidende
maßnahmen geeinigt hatten
und wir hatten vereinbart dass wir an
diesem wochenende eine zwischenbilanz
ziehen werden heute am sonntag stellen
wir überall in deutschland fest unsere
städte unser verkehr
unser wirtschaftliches und privates
leben sehen vollkommen anders aus als
noch vor einer woche
die überwältigende mehrheit der menschen
hat verstanden dass es jetzt auf jeden
und jede ankommt dass jeder und jede
sein und ihren teil dazu beitragen kann
aber auch muss das virus aufzuhalten
bevor ich ihnen gleich im einzelnen die
erweiterten leitlinien erläutere auf die
sich bund und länder heute geeinigt
haben ist es mir wichtig mich direkt an
all diejenigen zu wenden die sich jetzt
an die notwendigen verhalten
halten ich danke ihnen dafür
ich weiß dass es verzicht und opfer
bedeutet wirtschaftlich wie menschlich
wenn geschäfte schließen müssen wenn man
nicht mehr so einfach unter leute gehen
kann und was noch viel schmerzhafter ist
nicht mehr so einfach die großeltern
besuchen darf freunde treffen darf wir
alle müssen darauf eine zeit lang
verzichten
dass sich so viele an diese
verhaltensregeln halten das berührt mich
sehr so zeigen wir fürsorge für ältere
und vor erkrankte menschen
denn denen würde das virus am
gefährlichsten
kurz gesagt so retten wir leben
ich habe ihnen bereits am mittwoch
gesagt so dynamisch die ausbreitung des
virus ist so flexibel müssen wir unsere
maßnahmen auch immer wieder angehen
wir müssen sozusagen in der lage lärm
von den experten die der epidemie immer
neue erkenntnisse abgewinnen und von der
beobachtung der wirklichkeit welche
maßnahmen werden reibungslos umgesetzt
und wo hakt es noch
und warum in diesem sinne haben sich die
bundesregierung und die bundesländer
heute verständigt die leitlinien für das
verhalten und für die bewegungsfreiheit
und mobilität an die sich alle zu halten
haben noch einmal zu erweitern
so reduzieren wir weiter konsequent
öffentliches leben und die sozialen
kontakte und wir sorgen dafür dass in
ganz deutschland im grundsatz die
gleichen regeln gelten
viele bürger haben uns ja deutlich
wissen lassen dass sie sich diese
klarheit auch im föderalen staat
wünschen
jeder soll wissen alle staatlichen
ebenen in deutschland der bund die
länder und die kommunen arbeiten an
einem großen ja lebenswichtigen ziel
zeit zu gewinnen im kampf gegen das
virus
und deshalb haben wir uns auf folgende
leitlinien heute ergänzende leitlinien
verständigt die ich ihnen vortragen
möchte
die bürgerinnen und bürger werden
angehalten die kontakte zu anderen
menschen außerhalb der angehörigen des
eigenen hausstandes auf ein absolut
nötiges minimum zu reduzieren
zweitens in der öffentlichkeit ist wo
immer möglich zu anderen als den unter
eben genannten personen ein
mindestabstand von mindestens 1,5 meter
besser noch zwei meter einzuhalten
drittens der aufenthalt im öffentlichen
raum ist nur alleine mit einer weiteren
im haushalt lebenden personen also eine
weiteren im haushalt lebenden personen
oder im kreis der angehörigen des
eigenen hausstands gestattet viertens
der weg zur arbeit zur notbetreuung
einkäufe arztbesuche teilnahme an
sitzungen erforderlichen terminen und
prüfungen hilfe für andere individueller
sport und bewegung an der frischen luft
sowie andere notwendige tätigkeiten
bleiben selbstverständlich weiter
möglich fünftens gruppe feiernder
menschen auf öffentlichen plätzen in
wohnungen sowie privaten einrichtungen
sind angesichts der ernsten lage in
unserem land inakzeptabel
verstöße gegen die kontakt beschränkung
soll von ordnungsbehörden und der
polizei überwacht und bei
zuwiderhandlungen sanktioniert werden
sechstens gastronomiebetriebe werden
geschlossen
davon ausgenommen ist die lieferung und
abholung mitnahme fähiger speisen für
den verzehr zu hause sieben teams dies
dienstleistungsbetriebe im bereich der
körperpflege wie friseure
kosmetikstudios massagepraxen tattoo
studios und ähnliche betriebe werden
geschlossen weil sie in diesem bereich
eine körperliche nähe haben die ja
unabdingbar für die berufsausübung ist
und deshalb nicht zu den leitlinien die
wir uns gegeben haben passen medizinisch
notwendige behandlungen bleiben weiter
möglich 8
in allen betrieben und insbesondere
solche mit publikumsverkehr ist es
wichtig die hygienevorschriften
einzuhalten und wirksame schutzmaßnahmen
für mitarbeiter und besucher umzusetzen
und 9 diese maßnahmen sollen eine
geltungsdauer von mindestens zwei wochen
haben
damit weiß jeder wo immer er oder sie
lebt genau woran er ist
jeder soll seine bewegungen und sein
leben für die nächsten wochen nach
diesen klaren vorgaben organisieren
niemand von uns die wir in der
demokratie politische verantwortung
tragen hat sich gewünscht je mit solchen
regelung vor die bürger treten zu müssen
ich sage aber auch dies sind nicht
einfach irgendwelche empfehlungen des
staates es sind regeln die in unserer
aller interesse einzuhalten sind
die ordnungskräfte werden das überprüfen
und wo sie verstöße feststellen wird es
folgen haben und strafen geben ich
wiederhole daher meinen dringlichen
appell an sie alle gerade auch an die
wenigen die sich mit der einhaltung der
regeln in den letzten tagen noch schwer
getan haben bitte ziehen sie alle mit
tun sie jetzt das was richtig ist für
unser land zeigen sie vernunft und herz
unzählige mitbürger arbeiten im
gesundheitssystem oder halten unsere
tägliche versorgung aufrecht wir sollten
ihnen dafür immer danken
vor allem aber schulden wir ihnen dass
wir dem virus so wenig möglichkeit geben
sich auszubreiten wie wir das irgendwie
können
es ist an diesem tag eine große
ermutigung zu sehen dass millionen und
abermillionen von menschen diesen
verzicht aus gemeinsinn und fürsorge für
die gefährdeten auch ganz praktisch
leisten
ich bin überzeugt dieser gemeinsinn
dieses
betreten füreinander ein wird uns alle
gemeinsam durch diese schwere zeit
tragen
herzlichen dank frau bundeskanzlerin als
sie die maßnahmen vorgelesen haben haben
sie gesagt
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum ist
nur alleine mit einer weiteren im
haushalt lebenden personen oder im kreis
der angehörigen des eigenen haushalts
gestattet ist es muss doch heißen mit
einem fehler habe ich dann ein fehler
gemacht da lese ich gleich noch mal vor
damit was alles richtig haben
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum ist
nur alleine mit einer weiteren nicht im
haushalt lebenden personen oder im kreis
der angehörigen des eigenen hausstands
gestattet danke ich habe aber trotzdem
noch eine frage und zwar gab es ja
vorschläge die sanktionen kann ganz
konkret dort reinzuschreiben etwa 25.000
euro an strahlt strafandrohungen wenn
nicht aus dem kreis der
ministerpräsidenten kamen solche
vorschläge wenn nicht dieses
versammlungsverbot oder kontaktverbot so
zusagen eingehalten wird oder auch der
in die drohung mit freiheitsstrafen
warum ist das nicht drin und es soll ja
eine auseinandersetzung gegeben haben
zwischen den ministerpräsidenten söder
und laschet liegen die nerven blank
es hat eine wie immer lebendige
diskussion gegeben das ist aber auch
ganz normal von strafen oder
ordnungsgeldern ist heute nicht
gesprochen worden in welcher höhe das
hat überhaupt gar keine rolle gespielt
und ansonsten muss ich ihnen sagen es
ist doch wichtig dass wir uns darauf
geeinigt haben dass wir die kontakte
reduzieren dass wir trotzdem den
menschen erlauben wollen das haus zu
verlassen dass sie rausgehen können für
die notwendigen tätigkeiten aber eben
auch um frische luft zu schöpfen
das kann man in der familie machen mit
denen die im hausstand leben und eben
auch wenn man alleine lebt mit einer
zweiten person zusammen das wird
manchmal so geschrieben dass es
sozusagen im öffentlichen raum nur zwei
menschen zusammen sein können außer es
nennt sich um menschen die in einem haus
stand wohl und ich glaube das ist eine
gute und richtige regelung dass
finanzminister und ich ihnen hier an
dieser stelle auch zu einem statement
zur verfügung stehen die gesetze werden
erläutert werden wir sind noch voll im
verarbeitungsprozess und deshalb kann
ich zur ausgestaltung dieser gesetze
heute nichts sagen
es wird es wird kommen und die details
werden gerade noch abgestimmt es muss
sich keiner sorgen machen und die
überschriften heute in manchen zeitungen
waren auch vollkommen übertrieben
also da werden wir eine gute einigung
finden auch mit den bundesländern wir
haben ja eine bundesrats sondersitzung
am freitag
und wir wollen natürlich dass in dieser
bundesrats sondersitzung auch die
gesetze beschlossen werden das wäre ja
nicht besonders logisch wenn wir im
bundestag etwas verabschieden was
anschließend vom bundesrat nicht
mitgetragen wird
peter titel von der bild zeitung herr
laschet hat heute den begriff vom
kontaktverbot geprägt was halten sie von
dem begriff und wie werden sie
vielleicht einmal erläutern dass wir
sich selber ganz persönlich umsätzen in
der arbeit und in ihrem alltag und eine
zweite frage wie erklären sie die und
den bürgern dass er trotzdem dann ein
flecken dann ein flickenteppich haben
weil wir haben jetzt so ein grundgerüst
dass wir oft dass man sich gerade mal so
einigen konnte es gab ja streit das gibt
bundesländer die gehen weit deutlich
deutlich weiter wir haben bayern wir
haben sachsen und wir haben maßnahmen in
den kommunen wie zum beispiel freiburg
die deutlich weiter gehen wie erklären
sie dass sie die kontakte reduzieren
es ist ja so dass jeder noch kontakte
haben wird entweder mit den menschen mit
denen im haushalt lebt oder man kann
einen mit nach draußen nehmen und man
wird auch andere kontakte haben zum
beispiel über das telefonieren oder
skaten also kontakte sind ja nicht immer
nur dass man sich gegenüber steht 20
glaube ich dass ein grundgerüst das
jetzt sehr sehr ähnlich ist zwischen den
einzelnen bundesländern und das ja viele
bundesländer auch noch gar nicht alles
aus formuliert hatten aber
alle ministerpräsidenten haben heute
genau diesen leitlinien zugestimmt davon
sind nicht alle fall konstellationen
erfasst manche verordnung wird noch sehr
viel spezifischer sein aber dieses kamen
alle mitgetragen und ich glaube das sind
ja auch die grund botschaften an die
menschen und jetzt nochmal zu der frage
wie ist die auseinandersetzung wurde
geredet ist gibt natürlich diskussionen
das ist aber bei jeder mp konferenz so
wenn wir hier hinter ihnen in dem raum
sitzen dann geht das auch durchaus zur
sache dass es ja auch vernünftig ich
meine wir sind leben in einer echt
schwierigen situation
wir beschränken viele freiheiten die für
uns ganz selbstverständlich sind und
dass da unterschiedliche ideen auch
eingebracht werden das ist finde ich
normal
schauen sie doch mal wie sie hier sitzen
gucken sie mal wie wir unsere
kabinettssitzung machen
ich habe alle nahezu alle termine
abgesagt in denen menschen hierher
kommen ins kanzleramt oder in denen ich
zu menschen fahren würde also mein leben
hat sie auch grundsätzlich verändert und
besteht im wesentlichen aus telefon- und
videokonferenzen
der europäische rat findet die stadt es
finden keine reisen statt ich habe
fahren nirgendwo in deutschland hin wenn
ich besuche machen würde sonst als
termine also das alles entfällt frau
bundeskanzlerin vor gut einer woche gab
es ja schon mal den versuch dass die
länder und der bund sich einigen auf
eine einheitliche situation kurz danach
ist der bayerische ministerpräsident
wieder mit dem ruf nach verschärfungen
vorgeprescht nehmen sie ihm das
eigentlich übel und glauben sie dass das
bewusstsein vorherrscht dass das jetzt
nicht mehr zu diesen alleingängen kommt
sollen sie die lage ist sehr sehr
unterschiedlich wenn sie sich allein mal
die betroffenheit der einzelnen
bundesländer anschauen dann ist das
unterschiedlich und wir haben die
bundesländer bayern baden württemberg
und saarland insbesondere in gewisser
weise auch rheinland-pfalz aber die drei
die ich zuerst genannt habe ganz
besonders in
denen grenznähe da ist wo nachbarländer
auch bestimmte maßnahmen ergriffen haben
und die sind natürlich da noch mal
sensibel aber als dann auch immer gleich
zu verwerfungen in den pendlerverkehr
und so weiter kommen kann
und insofern geht es darum dass wir am
montag schon gesagt haben wir gucken uns
das mal anhalten sich die menschen dran
ich habe das ja auch mit bereits aufruf
gestartet
ich freue mich heute dass so viele dass
auch freiwillig machen aber es gab eben
auch situationen deshalb haben fast alle
bundesländer auch schon über das
wochenende die restaurants geschlossen
und die cafés wo wir gesehen haben dass
das mit den kontakt reduzierungen mit
den abstandsregelungen vor allen dingen
nicht so gut eingehalten wird ich will
vielleicht noch mal sagen es ist das
aller aller wichtigste dass die
abstandsregeln eingehalten werden die
frage wenn ich draußen bin und draußen
rumlaufen ist eben ganz ganz wichtig
abstandsregel denn mit einer bestimmten
abstand reduziert sich das
infektionsrisiko nahezu auf null
ob sie also einen halben meter
voneinander entfernt stehen oder 15
meter macht einen riesenunterschied auch
wenn man das vielleicht aus seinem
bisherigen leben so noch nicht gesehen
hatte ich bedanke mich